S
ANOTHER WORLD PREMIERE.
♪ ♪
♪♪ ♪
♪♪
[APPLAUSE]
>> Geoff: THAHAT'S YOUR FIRST
LOOK AT SCAVENGERERS, TELL US
ABOUT YOUR STUDIO.
>> MIDWINTER IS A NEW STUDIO O N
SEATTLE, WASHINGTON, WE ARE A
SMALL TEAM JUST OVER 20 PEOPLE.
MANY OF US COME FROM AAA
BACKGROUND, WORKING ON TITLES
LIKE HALO AND BATTLEFIELD AND
THIS IS OUR FIRST GAME IS A NEW
STUDIO
WE WENT WE GOT A TEASE OF THE
WORLD, WHAT KIND OF GAME IS AT?
>> IT'S A SURVIVAL SHOOTER
COOPERATIVE.
TEAMS NEED TO COOPERATE TO
SURVIVE BUCOMPETE TO WIN.
ALL THE ASPECTS OF A SURVIVAL
GAME AND CONDENSE IT INTO A
REPLACEABLE SESSION BASED
MULTIPLAYER EXPERIENCE.
>> Geoff: IF PEOPLE WANT TO
LEARN MORE THIS ATTACK TO SIGNU.
>> WERE GOING TO BE HAVING PLAY
TESTS AND PEOPLE CAN GO TO
SCAVENGERS GAME AND YOU'LL BE
AMONG THE FIRST TO PLAY
SCAVENGERS.
>> Geoff: IT'S AN AMAZING
WORLD PREMIERE FIRST LOOK AT
SCAVENGERS, SIGN UP FOR THAT
NOW.
IT'S NOW TIME TO PRESENT OUR
NEXT AWARD AND PLEASE WELCOME
THE FRONT MAN FROM PANIC A